this is my absolute favorite story of
the week and it's not getting a ton of
play because it relates to something
that happened like 50 years ago
very of Sachin littlefeather
you you may or may not remember Sachin
Little Feather when Marlon Brando won
the Oscar for The Godfather he didn't
show up he sent supposedly a Native
American to protest the the uh Academy
of Motion Picture Arts and Sciences this
was a Native American named Sachin
littlefeather
in The Godfather
foreign
accepting the award for Marlon Brando
and The Godfather Miss Little Feather
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hello my name is sasheen littlefeather
I'm Apache and I'm president of the
national Native American affirmative
image committee I'm representing Marlon
Brando this evening and he has asked me
to tell you in a very long speech which
I cannot share with you presently
because of time but I will be glad to
share with the Press afterwards that he
very regretfully cannot accept this very
generous award
and the reasons for this being are the
treatment of American Indians today by
the film industry
excuse me
this was one of the most famous moments
in the history of the Oscars apparently
John Wayne had to be restrained from
going up and just like throwing this
woman off the stage but it's a very very
famous moment one really kind of the
beginning of the politicizing of the
Oscars and making it all about this
partisan nonsense well anyway
it was 40 50 years later now it turns
out that that Apache lady Sachin
littlefeather
does not have one drop of Apache blood
in her she and you could you look at her
you say she doesn't really look Apache
to me it was completely fake she was the
Rachel dollazole of the Oscars
Sachin littlefeather her her biological
sisters Rosalind Cruz and Trudy Orlandi
uh say that little feather is not Native
American at all it's a lie my father was
who he was his family came from Mexico
and my dad was born in Oxnard
just not Native American at all and so
the reason I bring this up
is
to to
point out how long this kind of crazy
identity politics game has been going on
it's been going on a very very long time
and the kind of delusions of this and
the impulse for people to create their
own
identities
that are frequently divorced totally
divorced from reality and to claim a
kind of victimhood and and the idea that
victimhood carries currency this is not
just some new thing that the snowflakes
invented 10 years ago this this is a an
enduring feature of American politics
that goes back at least 60 years and I
think goes back much further than that
uh also
it it should give conservatives a little
bit of Hope
to think about In This Moment Sachin
littlefeather had
had become this symbol of progress civil
rights
Liberation breaking through the terrible
oppressive treatment of the Native
Americans and all this and then
now overnight
for the people who still think about
that moment at all its meaning has been
completely inverted now it's ugly it's
it's humiliating it's
preposterous it's wrong it's bad and it
reminds me of a line from Cardinal
Manning who I quote on this show a fair
bit Manning is the one who said that all
politics ultimately is theological is
another great quote he says there is a
day to come which will reverse The
Confident judgments of men in that day
the first shall be last and the last
first the wise in this world will be
fools and the fools in this world wise
the Mad in this world will be The Heirs
of a better
and this should give conservatives a lot
of confidence there is a day to come
which will reverse The Confident
judgments of men and it doesn't
necessarily feel like that at the moment
we feel like we are so put down that
Libs have all of the power they just lie
and lie in line there's very little that
we can do about it
but they I don't think that they will be
able to hold on to that power forever I
don't think the libs are omnipotent okay
and I think they are they are one of the
reasons they are clamping down so much
right now is they feel their power
slipping away they feel their grip
weakening right now on the American
political system I think that's why
they're becoming so much more hysterical
I mean if you were to
hear the story about January 6th
a year ago or a year and a half ago
even a great many conservatives would
believe that
the uh the Trump supporters were armed
they brought guns into the capital they
were about to rape AOC they killed
police officers they were just
exclusively storming the doors tearing
things down they probably set the damn
place on fire and the facts were not
in accordance with that narrative
in fact none of that was true obviously
there was bad stuff that went on people
broke windows and there was there was
plenty of bad stuff that went on but
AOC wasn't even in the building she was
in a different building nearby but you
know come on uh the only people who were
killed on that day at all were Trump
supporters and the only person who was
killed in political violence was Ashley
Babbitt who was killed by a trigger
happy cop the Trump supporters were not
armed that weren't busting in there with
AK-47s and AR-15s and crucially the
Trump supporters were permitted into the
capital in a great many cases cops moved
to the barricades cops opened the doors
in a great many cases
and just just that totally transforms
your understanding of that day of what
really went on
and it happens very often this happens
just as a matter of history and
historiography our our perception and
our conception of these kinds of events
and of historical figures and historical
movements and and the way that we view
human human nature in the world it can
change very very quickly and I think
that we are on the cusp right now of the
the liberal established view of the
world just collapsing and the people are
clearly clearly waking up about this
[Music]
[Music]